google cloud comes with built-in
infrastructure
and tools to help you develop apps and
manage your services
in this episode we'll go beyond login
and error reporting and explore
the powers of tracing profiling and
debugging
in production stick around
[Music]
google cloud log tools are great and i
hope you didn't miss the previous
episodes about cloud
logging and error reporting but when
dealing with logs
it's easy to get lost looking for needle
in a haystack
especially when you're trying to
determine where time is actually spent
when your application is carrying out a
particular task cloudtrace
is a distributed tracing system to help
you with this exact problem
by collecting latency data across
multiple google cloud products
and many supported languages in most
cases
cloud trace requires no setup the cloud
tracing graphical interface in the
console
provides recent traces each with uri
latency and timestamp but also most
frequent uris
and even insights pointing you to common
application problems
for any given request uri a heat map of
request duration through time
is presented giving you visual hints
about which specific requests may need
further
investigation capturing distributed
traces from your application used to be
a difficult problem
but we now make it easy with open
telemetry previously named opencensus
a project that we started here at google
for any running code that isn't
integrated
out of the box with cloud trace open
telemetry provides libraries that
capture
traces and application metrics from your
applications
either automatically using included
instrumentation
or manually via the api once you've
identified a particular bottleneck
in your application that is likely to
require a code modification
it's time to use a profiler what's
special about
cloud profiler is the little to no
overhead that it introduces while
continuously gathering
cpu and memory allocation data from your
production applications
cloud profiler then attributes that
information back to the application's
source code
helping you identify what's consuming
the most resources
and how to fix your performance issues
once collected
profiling data is displayed using flame
graphs
which pack a large amount of information
into a compact
and readable format this is not the time
to go into a course on troubleshooting
your code
but i would instead recommend that you
interact with a cloud profiler user
interface
click on the top functions list and find
out
which are the most expensive functions
and then click on one to enable the
focus view
they may well be some low hanging fruit
waiting for you
writing code is great but potentially
finding hard to identify bugs is just as
important
now be honest how often have you had to
restart
or redeploy your application just
because you added a log statement for
debugging
i know i have cloud debugger is a tool
you can use to inspect the state of an
application
at any code location without stopping or
slowing down the running app
since we're talking about live running
applications here
there are no actual breakpoints but
instead two
unique features snapshots and log points
with snapshots you can capture the call
stack
and inspect local variables all without
stopping or slowing down the app
with log points you can inject logging
statements
without the need to restart the app
creating a lock point is a lot like
creating a snapshot
simply click on a given line in your
code and each log point
will operate just as a log statement
that you write
into your code manually you can add free
text
reference variables and set the
conditions for the log to be saved
log points are written to your standard
output which means that you can
use them with any logging backhand this
is no conventional debugging tool
it's one that can help you troubleshoot
hard to reproduce problems
so i can only strongly encourage you to
look into it
with cloudtrace profiler and debugger
in your toolbox you now have modern and
powerful tools to diagnose and fix
issues that may arise in your cloud apps
even in production
if you like this video please like
subscribe comment
share and look forward to more google
cloud essentials videos
you